you know the the finite mindset is still
the majority mindset in how we lead our
nations and how we definitely lead our
companies
and we're seeing it we start with brexit
i mean we see it in various forms it's
all finite-mindedness
right um and and it is a result of
30 or 40 years of finite-minded leaders
creating systems and promoting finite
minuses
until these things build and break and i
think we're in a period right now
of a lot of cracks and breaking that
that are not because of today
they've been building up over 30 and 40
years
um and so we have to suffer through this
period of upheaval
but to balance that off uh
we have conferences like this we're
having conversations about
purpose we're having conversations where
we talk about putting people before
profit
we're having conversations about
mindfulness and you're not considered
crazy
to say that out loud on a stage you're
not considered a
nut job if you say i want to build a
company that stands for something
more than the products we make so the
point is i think the momentum
to change the way the things are is on
our side
you know this this message is spreading
and these events are getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and the books
that are promoting these ideas are
selling more and more and more
in other words there's demand we want
these things we know the system that
we're in is broken
but unfortunately we are the ones that
have to do the work to fix it
and and right now the dam is leaking and
we can't point to them and say well
it's broken i know but we're up there
fixing it
but we're gonna get wet we're gonna get
wet for a while
you